في الشارع الفرنسي لا يزالان متواصلين
لينذر بالمزيد من الهزات السياسيه
والاضطرابات الاجتماعيه بعد تمرير اصلاح
نظام التقاعد المعارضه تسعى لاسقاط
القانون ومعه الحكومه بعد ان اخفق نوابها
في الجمعيه الوطنيه الفرنسيه في حجب الثقه
عنها مساعي المعارضه رافقتها اتهامات تشكك
في شرعيه الرئيس الفرنسي الذي بات مستقبله
على المحك اتهامات قد تدخل البلاد في ازمه
حكم هي الاولى في تاريخ فرنسا
الحكومه ميته بالفعل في اعين الشعب
الفرنسي ولم تعد تتمتع بالشرعيه
كذلك كان لها راي اخر حيث اتهمت رئيس
الفرنسي بالفشل الذريع غير ان ماكرون رد
بطريقه ضغط عليها الدبلوماسيه
اقول لك بمسؤوليه انا لا اتطلع الى اعاده
انتخابي لا يمكنني دستوريا لكن بين
استطلاعات الراي والمدى القصير والمصلحه
العامه للبلاد اختار المصلحه العامه
للبلاد وسائل الاعلام المحليه وحتى
الغربيه اعطت اهميه كبيره لما يحدث في
فرنسا منذ بدايه الاحتجاجات الرافضه لهذا
الاصلاح صحيفه لوبينيون الفرنسيه المحسوبه
على الليبراليين اكدت ان الازمه قد تتفاقم
والحكومه ستتعرض لخسائر كبيره مجله
انتقدت كل الكتل الحزبيه اليساريه وحتى
اليمينيه في تعاملها مع هذا القانون ووصفت
حكومه بان بالمتعثره اما صحيفه قالت بان
يتعمد بشكل اقل او يعتمد بشكل اقل على
مؤسسات الدوله لفك الجمود وهو ما تسبب في
انقسام ديمقراطي اما صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
اشارت في وقت سابق الى ان الرئيس الفرنسي
في حاله ضعف وبات اكثر عزله وهو في وضع لا
يحسد عليه اما صحيفه الديل التليجراف
فوصفت ماكرون بالبطه العرجاء وبانه لم يعد
قادرا على الحكم في اشاره الى حاله من
الانهيار الديمقراطي في فرنسا في حين
اشارت وسائل اعلام المانيه الى ان ماكرون
تحدى الشعب والبرلمان في نفس الوقت بتمرير
قانون الاصلاح